Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Vivre ?
Ou être vivant ?
Telle est la question.
Quelle est la différence
entre être vivant et vivre ?
Parmi vous, qui pense être vivant ?
(Rires)
Quand-même !
Qui pense vivre ?
Ah, pas mal.
Être vivant, c'est une notion biologique.
On dit d'un organisme qu'il est vivant
s'il remplit cinq critères bien précis.
Il naît,
il grandit,
il se nourrit,
il se reproduit
et finalement, il meurt.
Et vivre alors ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Est-ce synonyme d'être vivant
ou est-ce autre chose ?
Est-ce une notion qui change
en fonction des années, des personnes,
des expériences ?
Pour moi, c'est clair,
il y a plusieurs définitions.
À 10 ans, par exemple,
vivre, c'est être une graine
qui sort de terre.
C'est vouloir tout découvrir.
C'est passer des heures à dessiner
attablé à son bureau,
à construire des robots géants qui
se transforment en voiture ou en avion.
C'est des après-midis à faire
des gâteaux avec sa grand-mère.
Racler le saladier avec les doigts,
carrément des fois avec la langue.
C'est regarder Goldorak,
Albator, Capitaine Flam,
à la télé le mercredi après-midi
(Rires)
et le week-end, repasser en boucle
les cassettes vidéo de Star Wars,
Indiana Jones, Retour vers le futur,
même quand on les connait par cœur.
C'est aller à l'école
en traînant un peu les pieds
car on est timide
et qu'on n'a pas beaucoup d'amis
et que de toute façon, rentrer à la maison
si on n'a pas la meilleure note,
ce n'est jamais assez bien.
C'est lire des tonnes de BD,
s'allonger sur son lit pour rêver
et s'inventer des univers fantastiques
dans lesquels on est le plus fort,
on est le héros.
C'est aussi vouloir grandir
un peu trop vite
et essayer de se rebeller.
Mais juste un petit peu,
de peur de prendre une bonne raclée
qui de toute façon finira par tomber.
À 20 ans, vivre,
c'est l'arbuste qui grandit.
C'est devenir adulte tout en gardant
un peu de son âme d'enfant.
C'est sortir de sa chrysalide
et se sentir maître du monde.
C'est être avide d'expériences,
de découvertes, de nouveautés.
C'est croquer la vie à pleines dents
sans se soucier du lendemain.
C'est rigoler,
faire la fête,
aller en boîte,
faire des voyages.
C'est se réveiller le matin
sur une plage à Barcelone
après une soirée bien arrosée.
Faire des rencontres,
faire des conquêtes.
C'est vivre ses premières
grandes histoires d'amour.
Mais aussi ses premières désillusions
et ses premiers gros chagrins.
Vivre à 20 ans,
c'est aussi vouloir devenir pilote,
comme Maverick dans Top Gun.
Et finalement, finir à la fac
à cause d'un problème aux yeux.
(Rires)
C'est faire des études
sans vraiment savoir pourquoi.
Se perdre un peu en route
et finir par devenir ingénieur,
comme maman et papa.
Ce qui nous amène à la vie
à 30 ans, la fleur de l'âge.
30 ans, c'est toujours
avoir 20 ans dans sa tête,
mais avec plus d'expérience
et de maturité.
C'est surtout ne plus penser
uniquement à soi.
C'est fonder une famille.
Avoir de magnifiques bébés.
Avoir des amis en or sur lesquels compter.
Habiter dans une belle maison
et avoir une bonne situation.
Voilà, c'est ça la vie à 30 ans.
Bon, il y a aussi deux ou trois petites
choses qui ne fonctionnent pas très bien.
C'est un détail, mais ...
je vous en parle
parce que c'est vous.
30 ans,
c'est le temps des questions.
Pourquoi passer mes journées
sur un ordinateur ?
Pourquoi mes chefs ne reconnaissent-ils
pas la qualité de mon travail ?
Je suis insatisfait.
Alors, plutôt que de me poser
des bonnes questions
et d'essayer d'y chercher des réponses,
je me drape de mon plus bel habit
de super victime
et je choisis la solution
la plus facile : la fuite.
Comme Forrest Gump,
je m'amuse à courir :
« Cours Forrest, cours ! »
(Rires)
Courir, au début,
c'est un vrai plaisir.
C'est envie de me dépasser,
de repousser mes limites.
Alors je cours 10 kilomètres,
puis des marathons,
je continue et j'enchaîne,
jusqu'à la blessure.
Pas grave.
Je passe à la peinture,
à la photographie,
je gagne des concours,
je fais des expositions.
Je fais le maximum pour réussir
et pour que mes efforts soient reconnus.
Mais je reste insatisfait.
Je vis le syndrome de l'imposteur.
C'est ça la vie à 30 ans.
Mais heureusement, de l'extérieur,
c'est une vraie réussite.
À l'intérieur cependant,
je suis tout le temps stressé.
Est-ce génétique ?
Psychologique ?
Une idée, une tension, une pensée ?
Normalement,
le stress prévient d'un danger.
À court terme,
il nous aide à réagir efficacement.
Mais à long terme,
il exacerbe les émotions.
Il génère des tensions physiques
et mentales débilitantes.
Et quand la soupape
de sécurité explose,
la fatigue, la colère,
la dépression apparaissent.
En 2019,
40 % des travailleurs français
de 30 à 50 ans
sont régulièrement victimes de stress.
L'American Medical Association
affirme aujourd'hui que le stress
est la cause principale
de 60 % des maladies et des affections,
incluant le cancer
et les maladies cardiaques.
C'est plus que la cigarette
et le cholestérol.
Alors oui, le stress est aujourd'hui
un fléau qui nous touche tous,
plus ou moins,
et qui pèse sur notre santé.
Mais à 30 ans, la santé,
ce n'est pas important.
J'ai plutôt envie de vous parler
de la vie à 40 ans.
Vivre à 40 ans,
c'est passer quatre heures par jour
à me balader dans la nature.
À sentir le soleil sur ma peau,
à m'extasier du spectacle
des feuilles mortes qui tombent en hiver.
C'est faire des changements
d'alimentation.
Essayer tout un tas de médecine naturelle,
tout ce qui peut aider
mon corps à aller bien.
C'est avoir une femme merveilleuse
qui gère tout d'une main de maître,
qui s'occupe bien des enfants
et aussi de moi.
C'est avoir une famille
et des amis qui sont présents
et un sentiment de vivre, enfin.
Je me sens bien.
Je me sens léger.
Je ne travaille plus.
Plus de stress.
Une réelle délivrance.
C'est un peu comme les grandes
vacances au lycée :
un vrai retour aux sources.
Mais vivre à 40 ans,
c'est aussi une tumeur censée bénigne
qui est en fait un cancer rare
et agressif.
Ce sont des cycles de chimiothérapie
menés tambour battant
pour essayer de prendre
la maladie de vitesse.
Ce sont des journées entières,
roulé en boule sur mon lit d'hôpital,
les rideaux tirés,
le cœur au bord des lèvres
en attendant que ça se termine.
Vivre à 40 ans,
c'est me sentir peu à peu mourir.
Alors, après des mois d'opérations,
de chimiothérapie, de rayons,
le bout du tunnel apparaît enfin,
et je commence à remonter la pente.
Il est temps de recommencer à vivre.
À vivre ?
Ou à être vivant ?
Parce qu'apparemment,
je ne suis pas complètement guéri
dans ma tête.
Quand je vais mieux,
je retourne faire le même travail
dans la même entreprise,
au même poste toxique,
avec encore plus de stress et de pression.
Et là, dans ma tête, c'est le déclic.
De l'extérieur,
les circonstances sont les mêmes.
Mais à l'intérieur, tout est différent.
Pourquoi ?
Les épreuves de ces derniers mois
m'ont fait prendre conscience
de ce qui est essentiel.
Mes choix sont différents.
Je n'accepte plus
ce qui est toxique pour moi.
Alors, je renonce à cette promotion
et je change de travail.
Mon cancer m'a rendu la vie.
Alors, pourquoi être
devant vous aujourd'hui ?
Parce que je souhaite
à chacun d'entre nous de vivre.
De vivre vraiment.
De vivre maintenant.
Aujourd'hui,
je voudrais être votre thérapie
sans avoir besoin d'aller
jusqu'à la maladie.
Et je veux vous demander :
vivre,
c'est quoi pour vous ?
Comment vivez-vous ?
Qu'est-ce qui vous rend vivant ?
Moi, ce qui me rend vivant aujourd'hui,
c'est de prendre du temps.
De me relâcher.
De m'apaiser.
Comme le dit Serge Bianchi,
il est urgent de ralentir.
De faire des choses qui nous font du bien.
Qui nous donnent de la force.
Qui nous remplissent de l'intérieur.
Oublions un peu nos obligations
et soyons égoïstes.
Apprenons à dire non.
Que ce soit à nos enfants,
à notre conjoint, à notre travail,
à nos amis.
Apprenons à dire non
lorsque nous sentons
que nos limites sont atteintes.
Entourons-nous de personnes positives,
bienveillantes et qui nous font du bien.
Essayons de mettre notre esprit au repos.
Connaissez-vous
Pensouillard le hamster ?
Non ?
C'est une petite bête qui court
dans sa roue dans notre tête,
qui nous rend la vie et dure
et nous empêche même parfois de dormir.
Derrière le tapage incessant
de Pensouillard,
se cache notre égo.
Il nous fait souffrir.
Il nous leurre.
Il nous empêche d'être libre.
Alors, observons un peu ses mouvements,
amusons-nous de ses pitreries,
puis ralentissons
pour finalement trouver la paix.
Cessons de remuer cette boue
qui obscurcit nos pensées.
Laissons la terre retomber au fond
et l'eau claire remonter à la surface.
Car oui, nous avons besoin
d'avoir les idées claires
pour prendre conscience
de ce qui est essentiel pour nous.
Pour nous reconnecter à nos racines,
pour prendre les bonnes décisions
et vivre.
Aujourd'hui, mesdames et messieurs,
j'aimerais vous donner un petit
traitement, une petite prescription.
Prenez une bonne dose
de méditation quotidienne,
20 minutes de yoga après le repas,
un soupçon de relaxation,
de la marche hebdomadaire
et une semaine de jeûne annuel.
Un vrai retour aux sources, non ?
Ce sont là mes traitements réguliers.
Car se reconnecter à son moi profond,
lâcher prise,
prendre conscience de ses priorités
et oser choisir
ce qui est le mieux pour nous,
c'est ça, la définition de vivre.
N'ignorons pas notre besoin de vibrer,
de nous dépasser, de nous élever.
Nous en avons besoin.
Tout le monde en a besoin.
Arrêtons de ressasser le passé,
le futur, les prochaines vacances,
la prochaine fois.
Vivons ici et maintenant.
Et comme dit Oscar Wilde :
« Vivons !
C'est la chose la plus rare
au monde. »
La plupart des gens
se contentent d'exister.
Ne nous contentons plus d'exister,
d'être spectateur.
Prenons les bonnes décisions,
faisons les bons choix,
et vivons !
Merci.
(Applaudissements)